let's go ladies all looking great today
thanks for taking your time
okay so I just want to jump into it
Francesca hell of a season you had a big
season
um obviously got to explore your
relationship with Damian but it didn't
work out I want to know what is your
perfect match what are you looking for
in your perfect match
um I'm in a very happy relationship
right now so I think I definitely found
my perfect match off the show and being
on the show I learned a lot about what I
needed as a partner so I like someone
who's sweet and who treats me like a
princess and who's not afraid to like
get dirty in the kitchen and like likes
to do laundry and clean and like just
basically I'm like the queen of the
house and that's it yeah just someone
who like Is On My Level too and who's
like uh secure with themselves and
financially stable
yeah that's a good thing those are yeah
those are some good qualities I like
that yeah I'm happy to hear you're in a
happy relationship though
congratulations yeah George I want to
jump to you uh perfect match winner I
don't know if it's called a winner but
you know you made it how did it feel how
did it feel to get to the end with dom
and what are the qualities that Drew you
towards Dom
it was just a surreal feeling I guess
because there's so many strong couples
at the end
um it was nice to see that people
um saw how genuine me and Dom were and
how much we got along because it
obviously came down to a road and you
know I was like really grateful that
people could see that we had a
connection
um but yeah unfortunately we're not
together at the moment we did explore
things outside of the show but there
were a lot of factors that got in the
way and it's just a different
environment when you leave something
like that so yeah absolutely and I would
be remiss if I asked you know you and
Francesca you've both you know you both
did a Dom you both dated Harry at one
point
um do you guys have like the similar
taste like what is it about these guys
that you guys are both liking well I
mean when we're in a house where there's
like five guys it's gonna happen at some
point with someone you know so that was
like you know so strange but also
outside of the show Harry and me like
weirdly from the same place in Australia
where very similar people like we kind
of met on his podcast and just got along
it was like effortless so I don't know
if we have the same type but it seems
that way I guess but it was so
unintentional like Francesca's amazing
and we get along so yeah I don't know
it's just weird I love glass I like that
Chloe uh you and Shane got together so
how are you guys doing now I'm just
curious and are you still on a civil
level with Mitch what can you what can
you talk to me about that me and Mitch
will always be buddies always be really
good buddies
um he is such an amazing person and I
feel like I'm so glad that me and Mitch
are friends because clearly we explored
the road of love and it just didn't work
um so yeah we're still friends but yeah
the same road
me and Shane aren't together
we didn't end up making it I feel like
after the Villa it was just
it should be effortless when you first
meet someone and you fall in love and
then you kind of like move in with them
and stuff and it was just a little bit
harder than what I imagined but for all
the right reasons because I know what I
want in a man now and I'm still looking
for my perfect match
all right we're still looking I like to
hear it I like to hear it you're back uh
and Sophia I want to end with you real
quick if you could go back and change
one decision you made because you know
you got done a little bit dirty I didn't
like how they did you in there what
decision would you change my girl
I don't know that I would have changed
my decision to
um send Zay home and that's because that
was a message to myself and that was a
message to other women
um the reason why I sent Zay home is
because I had a conversation with
Savannah where
um she told me that they asked her to
match and although that night I intended
to match with Zay again once I heard
that I I knew that that was not an
option and I wanted I was nobody's um
second option I was
um and I wanted to like choose myself
and that's why I went with Chase um I
was like oh let's let's give it a try
because I'm sorry like Calvin
um
The Vibes weren't there so I was just
like well who's my next best shot so
that was Chase so I don't regret that
decision
um he made me regret that decision but
you know
um I don't regret you know picking him
over his eye
you know the full suit on the beach was
a little bit you know tough to overlook
but uh Hey know your know your worth add
tax I love it you guys are all beautiful
I appreciate you taking the time and
congratulations on the new season
yesterday all right what up boys what up
what up what up dog man I gotta say I
was rooting for you fellow Toronto guys
so I was pulling for you and you are the
perfect match you got it so I gotta ask
you man like what were your favorite
qualities in Georgia what what Drew you
to Georgia
I think immediately for me it's just
authenticity I think the moment that we
matched and we were up the entire night
talking and talking about our personal
lives and she always stayed true to who
she was she was genuine loyalty trust
communication and you know obviously
she's an absolutely gorgeous human
inside and absolutely stunning so
uh yeah she was just overall the perfect
package all right sounds like a good
match to me Maya yeah Joey Joey man I
gotta ask you you say the words Nick
Lachey so much in the season like the
full name are you a big Nick Lachey fan
or like what was going on with that bro
here's the thing I grew up loving
Nicholas I watched them on TV I
didn't know he was hosting this so like
I could never be like yo what's up Nick
like that's just like yo we are not on
first name bases like that that is Nick
Lachey In the Flesh it never I never got
tired of seeing him I never got tired of
saying if he walked in right now it's
Nick Lachey yeah that's Mr Lachey I got
you
so Joy unfortunately you were unable to
win the show but you did get engaged
yeah wild so tell us about the future
with carousel you know honestly none of
us really knew anything about there
being a winner we were just trying to
get it to the end and honestly at that
point in time I'm just I'm asking
someone to marry me so even if I was
told there's gonna be a win I'm not
thinking about that what it's like I'm
about to ask someone to marry me this is
crazy I gotta call family members I
gotta orchestrate things and yeah it was
it was beautiful man it was one of the
most beautiful days of my life and when
the show you know ended and we went back
to our lives we both just got to a point
where we realized things weren't the way
they probably should be
and we have nothing but love and respect
for each other we like to keep our
private life private we because we let a
lot out on the show and it feels nice
just to have something stay just between
us but yeah I think that we're really
working on our friendship and always
wanted to be part of each other's lives
because we see each other and we have so
much love and respect and no regrets at
all with anything
hey we love a mature relationship man we
love that we love to see it absolutely
and Mitch I would be remiss if I didn't
ask you my guy you say on the show that
you weren't really ready for a
relationship so how come you hopped on
to a perfect match this year well the
problem is you don't know that until
you're about to get in a relationship
I didn't know that coming on the show I
thought I was ready and then especially
when it came up with me and Chloe were
on the show I was like oh okay and I
started just realizing some of the
things that didn't work out in the past
and full responsibility I had to work
through a lot of things the last couple
years and I still am and I didn't
realize about myself I have such a
loving
deep heart for so many people but when
it comes to actually being in love I am
scared of that like I am like it's
horrifying hold on yeah like do I like I
almost question it because I'm like I
don't know if I want to let this piece
of my heart out
um and I didn't know that about myself I
feel like you only find that out as you
start falling in love and then I was
like oh this is slippery this is scary
I'm it's a different kind of love than
just like hey I love my boys you know
right I learned that on the show that
was a big breakthrough for me hey we
love a guy with self-awareness so hey
kudos to you for that my brother and I
gotta ask all you guys because the fans
want to know who would you say it was
the villain of the show who was who was
the one roughly the most betters in
there I mean I think Chase comes to mind
immediately because he made out of my
girl night one and me and Chase are boys
and we had to have that sit down and
talk about things but Chase likes being
the villain of the house man he likes
coming in letting people know he's here
and he's here for business yeah I think
Chase takes the crown there has to be
Chase I don't know I hope I didn't
accidentally become the villain because
I